♪ ♪
>> Jeanine: IT HASN'T BEEN A
GOOD WEEK FOR MAINSTREAM MEDIA
MOB AND INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
RECENTLY FOUND THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT ORDER
OFFICERS TO CLEAR AND TEAR GAS
BLACK LIVES MATTER PROTESTERS
AHEAD OF HIS VISIT TO ST. JOHN'S
CHURCH LAST YEAR.
THIS, DESPITE THE ARMY A
FACT-CHECKERS AND REPORTERS WHO
REPORTED THE EXACT OPPOSITE
DOESN'T DON'T LIKE OF TIMES.
TWITTER IS HAVING AN ABSOLUTE
MELTDOWN OVER THEIR DECISION TO
PUT JEFF TOOBIN BACK ON THE AIR
AFTER HIS ZOOM MASTURBATION
SCANDAL.
HE ATTEMPTED TO SET THE STORY
STRAIGHT IN THIS PAINFULLY
AWKWARD INTERVIEW ON CNN.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS ONE.
>> I FEEL LIKE WE SHOULD ADDRESS
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THE MONTHS
SINCE WE'VE SEEN YOU.
YOU WERE ON A ZOOM CALL WITH
YOUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE
"NEW YORKER" MAGAZINE.
EVERYONE TOOK A BREAK FOR
SEVERAL MINUTES DURING WHICH
TIME YOU WERE CAUGHT
MASTURBATING ON CAMERA PRETTY OR
SUBSEQUENTLY FIRED AFTER 27
YEARS OF WORKING THERE AND SINCE
THEN HAVE BEEN ON LEAVE SINCE.
TO QUOTE JAY LENO, WHAT THE HELL
WERE YOU THINKING?
>> OBVIOUSLY I WASN'T THINKING
WELL OR THINKING VERY MUCH BUT I
DIDN'T THINK I WAS ON THE CALL.
I DIDN'T THINK OTHER PEOPLE
COULD SEE ME.
>> Jeanine: ALL RIGHT, YOU
MEAN TO TELL ME THAT ALL YOU HAD
TO DO TO REDEEM YOURSELF IN THE
EYES OF THE FAR LEFT OF MEDIA IS
TO PROVIDE THE DEFENSE THAT YOU
"DIDN'T THINK OTHER PEOPLE COULD
SEE YOU."
WHAT DO THESE ACTIONS SAY TO THE
WOMEN OF CNN?
TWO REAL VICTIMS IN THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT.
CHINA MAY NOW WITH SOME A
REACTION JOE CONCHA HIMSELF
LET'S HEAR IT, JOE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> AS FAR AS HE IS CONCERNED,
THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT FOR IT AS
FAR AS WHAT ARE THE WOMEN OF CNN
NOW THINKING -- WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO YOU HAD CUOMO ON HOW TO
DEFLECT AND DISMISS
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATIONS, SOME
UP TO 35 YEARS YOUNGER THAN HIM.
THIS IS REVEALED -- ALSO BY THE
WAY COME AFTER CHRIS CUOMO FAKES
HIS OWN QUARANTINE OR AFTER HE
INTERVIEWS HIS BROTHER
GOVERNOR AT LEAST A DOZEN TIMES
WITHOUT ASKING ABOUT THE NURSING
HOME SCANDAL OR IS CAUGHT
COACHING MICHAEL COHEN ABOUT THE
QUESTIONS HE'S GOING TO GET AND
ALSO GIVES HIM THE ANSWERS.
AT AFTER ALL THAT, HE GETS NO
PUNISHMENT.
BUT PARTICULARLY ON ADVISING HIS
BROTHER ON HOW TO DISMISS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS,
HE WAS ACTUALLY REWARDED A
PODCAST JUST LAST MONTH.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET MORE CHRIS
CUOMO IN THE SITUATION.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO ASK, IF HE WAS
A LOWER LEVEL STAFFER, LET'S SAY
HE WAS A WOMAN OR A CONSERVATIVE
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW, RICK
SANTORUM.
DOES HE GET AWAY WITH THIS?
THAT IS A RHETORICAL QUESTION
FOR THE BOTTOM LINE IS, CNN IS A
BOYS CLUB.
8:00 P.M., 9:00 P.M., 11:00 P.M.
THAT ISN'T THE CASE AT FOX AND
IT'S NOT EVEN THE CASE AT MSNBC.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> Jeanine: JOE, IT IS JUST
AMAZING TO ME THAT SOMEONE WOULD
BE ON A ZOOM CALL AND ACTUALLY
DO THAT.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY CAN SEE YOU
OR THEY DON'T SEE YOU.
AND HE SAYS, I DON'T KNOW, I
WASN'T THINKING.
YEAH, YOU WERE THINKING ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE.
WHAT WERE YOU DOING ON THE CALL
TO BEGIN WITH?
I MEAN, IT'S JUST SO
UNFATHOMABLE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> LISTEN, IF CNN WASN'T A JOKE
BEFORE IT IS CERTAINLY A JOKE
NOW.
ALSO A LOT OF US IN MAINSTREAM
MEDIA HAVE HOME STUDIOS.
I CAN'T IMAGINE EXCELLENTLY
DOING SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
BUT FURTHERMORE, LET'S TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE CANCELED CULTURE MOB
THAT HAS GONE AFTER SO MANY IN
THE LAST SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR
AND IMAGINE IF THIS GENTLEMAN IS
ABLE TO COME BACK ON AND BEYOND
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND TALK ABOUT
HOW HE'S HAD A ROUGH SEVEN
MONTHS AFTER DOING WHAT HE DID
AND SOMEHOW WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
FEEL BADLY FOR HIM?
LISTEN, HE HAS TO HAVE SOMETHING
ON SOMEBODY, BECAUSE EVEN CNN
COULDN'T EXCUSE THAT IF NOT FOR
A GREATER REASON.
IF THEY WERE TO COME AFTER ANY
OTHER NETWORK THEY WOULD'VE COME
AFTER HIM AND THEY WOULD'VE HAD
TO MOVE TO ANOTHER COUNTRY AND
NEVER BE IN MEDIA AGAIN.
SO WE HAVE TO BEG THE QUESTION,
WHERE IS THE CANCEL CULTURE MOB?
WHERE IS THE ME TOO MOVEMENT?
YOU WOULD THINK THEY WOULD BE
PRETTY UPSET ABOUT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS, BUT SADLY THEY ARE
NOT.
>> Jeanine: YOU KNOW, THE
INTERESTING PART OF IT IS THAT
THE WHOLE NETWORK, CNN, IS NOW
TARNISHED BY WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
AND AMERICA SEES THIS.
THEY SEE IT FOR WHAT IT IS.
THERE ARE A FEW THINGS YOU CAN
WATCH AND SAY OKAY, I GET THAT.
OR IT DOESN'T REALLY GET INTO
THE MAINSTREAM.
BUT JOE, YOU ARE IN THE MEDIA.
YOU KNOW THIS KIND OF THING --
THEY SEE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE WAY THE STANDARDS THAT THE
LEFT HAS HELD TWO, WHICH IS
THOSE STANDARDS AND THE RIGHT
WHICH IS AN OVER STANDARD.
>> COMPLETELY.
IT'S REFLECTING IN THE
VIEWERSHIP OVER AT CNN RIGHT NOW
WHERE THEY'VE LOST NEARLY 80% OF
THEIR PRIME TIME AUDIENCE SENDS
JUST THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
EIGHT AND TEN GONE.
HOW COULD ANYBODY EVER WATCH ANY
SEGMENT WITH JEFFREY TOOBIN EVER
AGAIN WHEN THIS IS THE FIRST
THING THAT'S GOING TO COME TO
YOUR MIND WHEN HE COMES ON THE
AIR.
LOOK, IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S
COMPLETELY INDISPENSABLE.
I'M PRETTY SURE THERE'S NO
SHORTAGE OF LEGAL ANALYSTS IN
THIS INDUSTRY THAT CAN REPLACE
HIM.
NO, NOT AT ALL.
AND TO YOUR POINT AGAIN, I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE CAMERA WAS
ON?
SO THIS IS A OKAY IF THE CAMERA
ISN'T ON DURING A WORK MEETING
WITH OTHER FEMALE STAFFERS?
AND THE NEW YORKER FIRED HIM
RIGHT AWAY.
CNN CONTINUED TO PAY HIM FOR THE
EIGHT MONTHS THAT HE HAD THIS
EXTENDED VACATION.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Jeanine: I WANT TO CHANGE
SUBJECTS AND TALK ABOUT WHAT I
DON'T LIKE HAPPENED AT THE
CHURCH OF ST. JOHN'S LAST YEAR
THAT TRUMP DON'T LIKE THEY SAID
THAT TRUMP TEAR GASSED THESE
BLACK GLOVES MATTER PROTESTERS.
THAT TURNS OUT CERTAINLY NOT TO
BE THE CASE.
AND I HAVEN'T HEARD OF ANY
RETRACTIONS BUT I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYONE SAYING I'M SORRY.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST A LIE.
AND THERE IS NO CONSEQUENCE IN
JOURNALISM FOR ANY OF THIS.
GO AHEAD, TELL ME.
>> ALL THEY DID FOR THE ENTIRE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS LIKE
COME ALIVE COME ALIVE.
BECAUSE THEY WERE DOING THE
BIDDING FOR THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
AND THEY STILL ARE PURE THESE
NETWORKS -- ALL THEY HAVE TO
RELY ON IS THERE TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
NOW THAT THEY NO LONGER HAVE
DONALD TRUMP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE -- AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IS
THE ONE THAT LOSES HERE.
NOT ONLY THE DO NOT SEE A
RETRACTION, BUT THIS IS HEADLINE
MAKING NEWS BUT IF THEY HAD
GOTTEN THIS WRONG ABOUT A
DEMOCRAT, WE KNOW THAT THERE
WOULD BE HEADLINES ABOUT THIS.
IT WOULD BE BREAKING NEWS ALL
OVER.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE
KNOW THAT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
DOES THE BIDDING FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTIES.
THE ONLY CARE ABOUT THE
NARRATIVES THAT DESTROY
DONALD TRUMP.
SO WE ARE NOT GOING TO SEE
ANYTHING NATIVE.
AT THE END OF THE DATE, AT THE
TIME IT WAS HAPPENING, WE KNEW
IT WAS A LIE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS SAYING THIS
WAS UNTRUE.
BUT NOBODY CARES.
THEY ARE ON THEIR FOUR YEAR
VACATION AND WE THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC ARE TRULY THE LOSERS.
AND THOSE WHO LISTEN TO THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA LIKE CNN,
MSNBC, THEY ARE LOSING ON A
DAILY BASIS AND I FEEL VERY
BADLY FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ONLY WATCH THAT NEWS.
>> Jeanine: YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
THE MEDIA PERSON HERE.
LET'S ASSUME THERE'S A
FACT-CHECKER SOMEWHERE IN THE
GROUP.
DO THEY ALL SAY, WHO CARES,
LET'S JUST SINK THEM SO THAT
JOE BIDEN CAN USE HIS DUMB LIKE
THIS AGAINST DONALD TRUMP AT THE
DEBATE?
I MEAN, SOMEBODY ON THE LEFT HAS
TO KNOW IT WASN'T TRUE, OR DO
ALL OF THEM KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE
AND THEY JUST DO IT ANYWAY?
>> THAT'S THE THING, THE THING
BETWEEN ALL THESE MEDIA
OUTLETS -- ALL CONFIRMING THE
OTHERS REPORTING, NOT ONE GOING
IN ANOTHER DIRECTION SAYING HEY,
WAIT A MINUTE.
WE CAN'T RECONFIRM THAT THE
PRESIDENT ORDERED THAT TEAR GAS
TO BE USED FOR IT ALL OF THEM IN
LOCKSTEP.
NOBODY'S GOING TO WAIT FOR THE
IG REPORT WHICH WAS DONE OVER
MONTHS AND WAS METICULOUS AND
CONCLUSIVE, YET YOU HAVE CNN
ANCHOR ACTUALLY ATTACKING THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HERE SAYING
HE'S AUDITIONING TO BE CENTRAL E
OFFERS NOTHING TANGIBLE TO THE
REPORT UNLESS SOPHOMORE YEAR
SNARK IS CONSIDERED TANGIBLE IN
THESE SITUATIONS.
SO HERE HE HAS COME THREE YEARS
OF THE MEDIA WORKING FROM A
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT
POSTURE.
OR HUNTER BIDEN'S EMAILS --
REMEMBER THOSE FROM HIS
ABANDONED LAPTOP THAT WAS DEEMED
TO BRANCHED DOWN MIKE RUSH AND
DISINFORMATION UNTIL IT WASN'T.
DOZENS OF INFORMATION -- THESE
ARE NOT MISTAKES, BY THE WAY.
WHEN IT HAPPENS THIS OFTEN, IT'S
INTENTIONAL.
>> YAH, BECAUSE THEY NEVER MAK